good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster a boost for the
government's coveted vaccine program
as it's extended for the third time this
week to include
all over 40s in england and a boost for
boris johnson with the conservatives
apparently extending their lead in the
polls
in spite of the row over the
refurbishment of his downing street flat
we'll speak to the home office minister
victoria atkins shortly
inner strength the woman lifting weights
as she
rebuilds her life following the sudden
death of her husband
[Music]
and the boilermakers bubbling along
nicely we'll talk to the
rising stars of british music royal
blood
it's friday the 30th of april
breaking news more than 40 people are
killed in a stampede at a religious
festival
in israel
we were standing and waiting for our
friends uh we were gonna
go inside for the dancing and stuff and
all of a sudden we saw paramedics from
madden whatever running by
like mid cpr on kids
denying any wrongdoing the actor and
producer noel clark
responds to allegations of sexual
misconduct as he's suspended
by bafta
rallying support for his spending plans
president biden marks 100 days
in office one million three hundred
thousand jobs
in one hundred days that's more june new
jobs in the first hundred days of any
president
in history please
sign up the nhs in england ask all
people over 40
to book their first coronavirus vaccine
appointment
opening a corridor the irish government
says it's considering plans for free
travel
between britain and the republic
and it's a case of sunny spells and
april showers for today but
how's it looking for the bank holiday
weekend i'll have the answer for you
later in the program
good morning we begin with breaking news
and at least
44 people have died in a stampede at a
religious festival in israel
ambulance officials say dozens more are
critically ill in hospital
it's believed a grandstand collapsed at
an event to honour an historic religious
leader
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
described the incident
as a heavy disaster ender brady reports
[Music]
this mobile phone footage was taken
moments after the stampede
men clambering through the gaps in the
corrugated iron to escape the crush
tens of thousands of ultra-orthodox jews
had gathered here in northern israel
to honor a second century rabbi the
crush happened
in the early hours of the morning we
were standing and waiting for our
friends
we were going to go inside for the
dancing and stuff
and all of a sudden we saw paramedics
from madame whatever running by uh like
mid cpr
on uh on kids uh and then one after the
other started coming on ambulances
uh then we understood like something's
going on here
ambulances lined the street as the
rescue effort continued long
into the night
casualties were transported to local
hospitals with
some airlifted 130 miles to jerusalem
it is a very challenging event in
general without
anyone being earth it's happening once a
year
for a couple of days it's a big big
celebrations of
tens of thousands of people that are
gathering
for about 48 hours sometimes even more
israel's prime minister benjamin
netanyahu called it a heavy disaster
it is one of the country's worst in
peacetime the lag bomber festival
is the first religious gathering of its
kind to be held legally
since israel lifted nearly all
coronavirus restrictions
authorities here had permitted 10 000
people to attend
but there are reports that a hundred
thousand showed up
and the brady sky news
well we can speak now to yoni jagadoski
from the israeli
ambulance service uh who joins us now
this morning
um good morning to you first of all tell
us about this festival it's been the
largest gathering
since covid and what exactly happened
[Applause]
well it is a huge gathering that happens
uh on a an annual basis last year didn't
happen because of the coverage and this
was kind of a celebration of the end of
uh between bamak here in israel
probably due to the crowds that were
gathering
in a relatively narrow path people were
simply
falling over and there was a lot of
crowd a lot of pressure of the crowds
magento de brum was at the site
with hundreds of medical personnel
like we're doing every year and
immediately responded
to the site began to treat the people
resuscitate those immediate
resuscitation
provide the advanced medical care
and begin the transportation to the
nearby hospital and
fire further on hospitals we have
deployed
close to 200 life-saving vehicles
in addition to the huge fleet that was
there
already since uh about uh
36 hours earlier
and what uh precipitated the disaster um
we understand correct as if if this is
wrong that there was some sort of
stampede what what brought that on
it's a it's a hilly area with
a lot of various buildings up inside and
the
ceremony that is conducted in a
relatively small area
it is timed through groups and groups
that are
doing their own ceremony around along
the night
and while people were already on the way
down
from the main ceremony
the path became was a little bit
narrower than in the beginning it's uh
walking down and people tripped over
those that were behind them simply
walk on them and that's what created
this
horrible horrible incident last night
would it be fair to say that the
capacity of the
the venue simply wasn't sufficient for
the number of people that attended
well i i according to the information
that
we have received
in previous years the gathering has
pretty much more than a double amount of
people there were their destination was
that there were about 100
000 people there in previous years we
used to have even
close to quarter of a million people
attending
so and the preparations were according
to these anticipation
in all aspects police
first aid fire department
uh security etc
but this incident happened i know that
it is
now under investigation and there will
be a foreign investigation about
the entire causes to this horrible event
done by the authority um
and we are as the emergency medical
services
provided the best services that we can
provide and
we know that people were in critical
condition but
they were able to reach the hospitals
and with our ambulances and now
we will need to figure out what to do
well we are also expecting funerals that
will happen
today in various places in israel it is
a huge
tragedy
okay yana yaga doski thank you very much
for speaking to us this morning and
bring us up to date with the situation
in israel
from the israeli ambulance service there
thank you as the row about allegations
of sleaze continue the government is
focusing its attention
elsewhere last night the new domestic
violence bill was passed by
parliament promising new protection for
victims
well let's speak now to the safeguarding
minister victoria atkins who joins me
this morning um are you confident that
the bill
having passed will completely protect uh
those in situations of domestic violence
we know that the numbers
have risen through uh lockdown and those
people now coming out
of lockdown will they be 100 protected
well this this bill is a truly landmark
bill we know that there are 2.3 million
adult victims of domestic abuse
in this country and of course children
who live within abusive households as
well
and this bill first of all puts a
definition of domestic abuse in many
forms it can take
but which is important for commissioning
of services at local level
but it does so much more than that we
are making real
meaningful changes to the ways in which
family courts operate
because we know that abusers sadly can
often try to use the family courts to
continue the abuse
we're prohibiting non-fatal
strangulation we're prohibiting
the use of threats to use revenge porn
we're
um making changes to the so-called rough
sex defense clarifying the law on that
so there's a huge amount of work that
we're doing
to help uh victims of domestic abuse and
also inc
critically to stop perpetrators we're
seeing record levels of investment under
this government
in programmes to stop perpetrators
because we've got to stop this cycle of
abuse this
perpetrator is going from one
relationship to another
and i think this is a real body of work
that the bill
provides the foundations for but we're
very conscious that the hard work starts
now
implementing it the bill however has
received criticism
of how it deals with with stalking after
the amendment
requiring offenders to be monitored on a
national
register was dropped why would that be
dropped i mean surely
a register actually keeping uh tabs on
offenders
is going to help those that are being
abused well in fairness i think this
bill has received
uh support from across the political
spectrum
i know you're focusing on that
particular point but genuinely this has
been a
real um it's been parliament at its best
i always say because
we've listened to ideas and suggestions
and where
we've been able to where we think they
will work we've absolutely listened and
then
acted on this particular measure we we
looked very very carefully at
it it's very technical it's about how we
manage serial offenders uh
and also the most violent and sexual
offenders outside of the domestic abuse
context as well as
within a domestic abuse context but we
have spoken we've worked really closely
with baroness royal who was the
peer bringing this amendment forward we
have um
very much understood some of the
concerns that have been raised we're
going to improve guidance we're i'm
setting out a new framework
we're finding ways to address the
concerns that have been raised in the
house
but we just we weren't convinced that
this particular amendment was the way to
fix that but of course
we will continue to keep this under
review a national register
is not a a good idea i mean many lay
people will think that it makes perfect
sense
yeah so the problem with registers um is
that
uh if someone what we don't want is
people
falling between the gaps so we have a
really really
um thorough system of managing a serial
offenders both
violence and sexual offenders as i say
both in and out of a domestic context
85 000 defenders are managed under this
system
of called mapper and um the
what we want to do they will be stalkers
but they will also be sadly sexual
offenders they'll
they will be um very very violent
offenders and
uh what we're doing is is looking at the
system as a whole we are very conscious
that
uh the some parts of the system have
outlived their usefulness the visor
system is more than 20 years old
so next year we will be piloting a brand
new digital
uh forum which we believe will really
answer some of these concerns that have
been raised but the critical point about
managing stalkers
is about the decisions that are taken at
local level to manage the risk of these
people
and that's what we need to focus on
rather than we think setting up a new
register
let's move on to uh the prime minister
regarding um
allegations of corruption and saying
that there's nothing
to see when the electoral commissioner
said
it has reasonable grounds to launch an
investigation
surely shouldn't the prime minister just
actually say
who paid for the refurbishments in the
first instance rather than allowing all
these investigations to be launched
well the prime minister has set out uh
his uh case very clearly actually in in
the house of commons on wednesday he was
the most direct question though has he
in the comments he didn't answer that
direct
question well he's answered the
questions that were put to him and and
um i know that he was asked yes or no
did he pay for the refurbishments and he
didn't answer yes or no
well as i say the prime minister has
answered those questions as you know i'm
on here to talk about the domestic abuse
bill
but the prime minister has answered the
questions he has very much
um given his answers to the house and
i do wonder you know here i am today
we've got this amazing
piece of legislation that will help as i
say millions of people
across the country and it would be nice
if just today we can focus on that well
we have we have that's how we started
the interview we have asked you about
that
but also people people are wanting to
have answers to questions that the prime
minister isn't simply answering
well i don't accept that as i say he's
answered questions in the house of
commons
uh we had the we've had the announcement
of uh lord geit
being appointed as the independent
advisor and of course you know
these reviews these inquiries will uh
take their
path but the prime minister has answered
to the house i don't really feel i can
add to that
but but ultimately as downing street has
said the prime minister will be the
the ultimate arbiter of of any inquiry
uh that's like marking your own homework
isn't it
well no the way that we work our
democratic system in this country is
that the prime minister
the prime minister of the day wins the
general election and
he or she appoints the government and
then he or she is answerable at the
dispatch box in parliament
and of course in due course at the
ballot box to the electorate
and so he must have control over who is
in his government he's answerable for
their actions it seems to me
the consequences of some of the
suggestions that have been flung around
in the press this week
haven't really been thought through i'm
not sure anyone wants
an unelected uh unaccountable advisor
impeccable and with all of the integrity
that
uh lord guy has i'm not sure that that
is an addition to our constitution that
uh we want to walk into without fully
understanding the consequences
we do know that sir alex allen quit the
role after the pm
essentially overrode his findings
regarding pretty patel
and bullying um how do we know that the
prime minister is going to listen to any
findings of
any investigation there are some nine
investigations at the moment
well first and foremost this process has
been transparent
uh and i think you know with in terms of
the previous investigation that has been
settled the home secretary apologized uh
on national television
um for the uh findings of that review
and so again i'm just i'm not sure i can
add anything more to whatever you
ignored it
the prime minister ignored it well
namely that um
the you know the the prime minister has
to have
the control of the government has to
have the
confidence that his ministers are the
ministers he wants to
exercise the incredible responsibilities
that
ministers have in government and that
seems to me that that
has always been the case and must
continue to be the case
minister thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning thank you
thank you well our political
correspondent
rob powell joins me now morning to you
rob but what did you make
of that well i think uh the government's
broader
strategy in dealing with these
allegations and accusations around the
downing street flats has been to try and
move
uh the story on talk about other things
that it says are more important
and that was clearly strategy this
morning no doubt
yes the domestic abuse bill is a very
very important piece of legislation that
a lot of work has gone into over a very
long time
and does deserve scrutiny and questions
as we just had
um there but i think when you look at
what's happening with the polling
it may well vindicate their approach the
government has been saying look the
public aren't bothered about this this
is a westminster
bubble story actually the polling does
show
that that lead the conservatives have
over labor going into this local
elections
doesn't seem to have been dented now
that doesn't mean that this isn't
important
and you touched on some of the issues
the broader issues which is
why these stories are important about
accountability about whether the
processes are robust enough
to hold ministers to account and i
thought that was the one area where
victoria atkins
did give a little she talked about the
independent adviser for ministerial
standards there's been a lot of
criticism of that post this week that
actually boris johnson
gets to make the final decision and can
overrule that independent
adviser calls for him to be made more
independent to be given more
powers to act um independently off his
own back
and what victoria atkins said was we
didn't want an unaccountable or
unelected
uh person operating in that way and that
wouldn't be a good addition to the
constitution there'll be a lot of people
in westminster
that disagree with that okay rob thank
you see you later in the program
the actor and director noel clarke has
denied allegations of
sexual misconduct the guardian newspaper
said 20 women who had worked with mr
clark
had accused him of harassment bafta has
suspended him
and withdrawn an award he won earlier
this month anisha sethi reports
i did actually have a speech prepared
which you've all now ruined
it's life of yours it's just too much i
couldn't do it nah man i love you
you sure yeah yeah yeah come here
he's a well-known actor director and
screenwriter
having showcased his talents in doctor
who and bulletproof
noel clark is now the star of itv's
latest
prime time drama so we would like to use
your flat for surveillance purposes
earlier this month he accepted bafta's
outstanding british contribution to
cinema award
hopefully people see that i've tried to
elicit change in the industry
so this is for the underrepresented
anyone who sits at home believing that
they can achieve more
now bafta has stripped him of the prize
following allegations of
serious misconduct the guardian
newspaper
details claims by actors and production
staff
who worked with clark some say they felt
pressured to take part in nude scenes or
auditions
others claim he subjected them to
unwanted physical contact
and made inappropriate remarks bafta has
released a statement
saying in light of the allegations of
serious misconduct
regarding noel clark in the guardian
bafta has taken the decision to suspend
his membership
and the outstanding british contribution
to cinema award immediately
until further notice the actor strongly
denies the allegations
and says in a 20-year career
i have put inclusivity and diversity at
the forefront of my work
and have never had a complaint made
against me
if anyone who has worked with me has
ever felt uncomfortable or disrespected
i sincerely apologize i vehemently deny
any sexual misconduct or wrongdoing and
intend to defend myself
against these false allegations every
day for a week which is supposed to be
your guest
clark was widely acclaimed for his work
in the hard-hitting film trilogy
adulthood adulthood and brotherhood
which explored life in inner city london
a rising star of bafta the actor's
career is
now on hold as the allegations are
investigated
henisha sethi sky news 100 days after he
took
office president biden has taken to the
road to sell his plans for a huge
trillion-dollar spending spree
mr biden spoke at a rally in georgia as
he tries to build support for a major
new infrastructure programme
our u.s correspondent mark stone reports
georgia was the state which propelled
joe biden to the white house
republican for nearly two decades it was
these supporters who flipped it blue in
november
and the president chose the place for a
victory lap 100 days on
1 million 300 000 jobs in 100 days
that's more june new jobs in the first
hundred days of any president
in history in america but it gave a hint
to that in this divided country he is a
president being pulled to the right
and to the left
we'll give you a microphone a heckler
calls for him to stop detention
relax immigration rules on the mexican
border
to the east of atlanta stone mountain is
a town
where they know all about the divisions
president biden inherited
these quiet streets were the scene last
year of angry protests
the backdrop was the town's
controversial history carvings on the
mountain of confederate generals
this was once the place where the ku
klux klan lingered
at the local martial arts club
instructor walter maddox is relieved
that all that is behind them
he hopes his focus is his business
and the new president he says has
delivered he's stepping into a lot of
things there was a lot of turmoil
there's a lot of
tragedy and i think it's in time uh
things will heal and things will will
definitely get better
we just got to be patient and just give
them a chance to work it out
young republicans like adam keller
believe the biden's successes are in
part an inheritance of republican policy
the rest he says are proof of a far-left
agenda
it's an advantage he thinks for the
return of trump
now you have an administration where
he's saying that he's centrist but his
actions and his policies are so far left
and when the middle see that they are
not really sure where
to go so part of our agenda that we need
to
really get across as far as republicans
go we need to find the middle again
outside the state capitol a hint of one
of the nationwide challenges
fallon mcclure is a local attorney and
democratic activist
i do think we have to move forward i do
think we need to come together
if we start thinking about how we're
more alike than different perhaps we can
start bridging that divide if america is
as president biden insists moving once
again
well it feels still to be in two very
different directions
mark stone sky news in georgia
also making the news this morning anyone
aged 40
and over in england can make a
coronavirus vaccine appointment
the nhs says nearly three-quarters of a
million people booked to receive the jab
on monday
and tuesday this week
brazil has become the second country in
the world to see its death toll from
coronavirus reach four hundred thousand
the health ministry reported more than
four thousand deaths in two days
less than six percent of brazilians have
been fully vaccinated against the virus
the online retailer amazon has announced
its profiles have
troubled the company's sale for the
first three months of the year rose 44
to almost 109 billion dollars irish
government says it's willing to consider
plans for a travel corridor between the
uk and the republic
the deputy prime minister leo veradka
said this could be introduced
instead of relaxing international travel
restrictions
the co-op supermarket says it will
remove all plastic bags for life from
sale
the company says it believes customers
are using them in the same way
as single-use banks
a reminder for you that you can see the
daily climate show later today that's at
6 30 p.m and 9 30 this evening here
on sky news
time now for the weather with naz and i
can just
see through the windows that the sun is
peeping up
yeah and there will be some sunny spells
around today but
in between there will be some april
showers some of them will be rather
potent as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
morning to you so it's a case of april
showers once again for today although it
starts off fine but as we see cloudier
skies develop this afternoon
there will be quite a few of these
showers cropping up and some of them
will be heavy and thundery and in fact
that's the story for the rest of the
week and for bank holiday monday it's
looking very wet and windy
until then fine this morning quite
chilly though frosty for central eastern
parts of england
there are some coastal showers
particularly heavy for southeast
scotland and northeast england
and then the showers become more
widespread this afternoon and the cloud
bubbles up some of them will be quite
slow moving with the light winds
and the risk of them being heavy and
thundery with some hail likely as well
so it is going to be quite wet at times
throughout today in between some drier
and brighter spells it's going to be
quite cool for the time of year where
temperatures
well below the seasonal average
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast the
end of a testing week for the prime
minister
we'll discuss whether allegations of
sleaze will have any effect
on next week's elections
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our main story this morning at least 44
people have died in a stampede at a
religious festival in israel
ambulance officials say dozens more are
critically ill
in hospital it's believed a grandstand
collapsed at an event to honor an
historic religious leader in mount meron
100 miles north of tel aviv
president benjamin netanyahu has
described the incident as a heavy
disaster
a short time ago yoni yagadovsky from
the israeli ambulance service told us
what happened
okay we'll bring you that from the
israeli ambulance service that
audio a little later on
the prime minister may say there's
nothing to see here as far as
allegations over the funding of his
downing street flat refurbishment are
concerned
but he was clearly riled by the labour
leader sakir stama
at pmqs what do we get from this prime
minister and this conservative
government
dodgy contracts jobs for their mates
and cash for access and who's at the
heart of it the prime minister
major sleaze sitting there this is a
government that is getting on with
delivering on the people's priorities
including tougher sentences mr speaker
for serious sexual and violent criminals
which he opposed mr speaker
we're getting on and by the way i forgot
to mention it i forgot to mention it
last night our friends in in the
european union voted to approve our
brexit deal
which he which he opposed well labour
are keeping up
the pressure but uh claims of sleeves
resonating with voters
ahead of next week's elections joining
me now
is victoria bowick a former tory mp and
former deputy mayor of london
under boris johnson along with professor
of politics at queen mary university of
london and the author
of the conservative party tim bale
welcome to you both good
morning um to you first of all victoria
uh
is there nothing to see
well i think the point is you know as
we've already seen from this morning
uh boris is still ahead in the polls and
the electorate i think are getting on
with what matters to them we've seen the
rollout
of the vaccine you know many parts
of the country now haven't had any
deaths and covered
over the last month you know things are
getting so much better
we've got our opportunity of living our
lives again seeing those we love in the
care homes
so how the prime minister's partner
decorates the dining street flat
i think has rather moved on so you're
you're subscribing to the the nothing to
see line but
uh professor tim bale we've rarely i
don't think ever
seen the the prime minister so riled uh
pmq's
he was really angry yes i mean i think
it is clear that kierstalmer
got to him at pmq's whether that means
necessarily that there is uh what some
people like to describe as cut through
with the electorate uh we'll have to see
and victoria's quite right when she says
the opinion polls suggest that it's not
affecting
uh the conservatives poll rating at the
moment however that is a different issue
uh from whether actually something
occurred here which shouldn't have
occurred and of course that's what the
electoral commission
are looking into if it was the case that
someone else initially paid for this
refurbishment however trivial that may
seem to some people
that that is an issue because it should
have been declared we do have rules for
a reason
and therefore it seems perfectly
reasonable for the electoral commission
to look into that
and victoria why not simply put all of
this to bed and answer that
that simple question who initially paid
for the refurbishments he was asked to
give
a yes or no answer by secure stamina
yesterday
and he didn't he had the opportunity and
he didn't
well i think that the point is that
inevitably the bills were paid and now
we know
and it's been confirmed that's that
isn't the point the point is who
initially paid for it in the first
instance not who
ended up paying for it in the end which
we know was boris johnson
yes that's what i was going to say
that's something we've now got several
inquiries
who are obviously going to investigate
the detail of
of all of this and exactly who paid in
in
what time and it'll all be sorted but
you know the important point is the
moment as far as we know
uh you know boris has paid the bills and
we've just got to sort out
now um exactly you know
whether that means there's going to be
changes in the system in the future
that's what the inquiries the inquiries
will do their bit the inquiries will
will do their investigation but you know
we have got an election time next week
we have kier stammer shopping in john
doe is tomorrow that wasn't an election
stunt
which just proves how this is all blown
out of all proportion
rather than getting on with what really
matters to people which is the only game
in time which is getting us better after
the and
after the can pandemic and sorting us
out
after coming sure that nine inquiries
points to it being blown out of all
proportion um professor tim tim bale um
we were talking before about uh the the
the polls and the fact that
actually the the conservatives boris
johnson's 11 points ahead of
of labor is it that people do not find
this in interesting at all or is it that
they're
simply used to allegations of corruption
um and they're used to to what's been
banded around us as sleaze
well i mean i think there is an extent
to which as people say
this kind of behavior is to some extent
priced in uh to boris johnson
uh he's never presented himself as a
paragon of virtue so people aren't
entirely surprised if it seems as if
he may not have acted in an appropriate
manner allegedly
um there is also uh the possibility
as you've suggested that um you know
many people think that there are more
important things going on the vaccine
roll out for example they're more
concerned about the economy and they're
feeling you know fairly optimistic about
that
it seems so you know that may make a
difference uh as well but i come back to
the point
is that we have to separate what people
think about this
and they may not think it's that
important from the fact that
it is possible that quite important
rules about transparency and declaration
etc have been broken and we can't get
away from that
those inquiries are important and of
course they could have consequences for
the prime minister and of course the
conservative party in the sense of
perhaps if the electoral commission do
find that something has gone wrong
uh the party may be fine some of the
other investigations particularly if one
involving the
commissioner for parliamentary standards
which labour are calling for now you
know finds boris johnson as
has uh acted inappropriately there is a
possibility that he could be
suspended temporarily from the house of
commons if that inquiry were to go ahead
so
there are consequences here and in some
ways there should be consequences
because we have to hold our
our public servants to uh high standards
otherwise
um things will begin to slip quite badly
and we don't want to live in a country
like that
and victoria if the electoral commission
does find that there has been
wrongdoing and boyce johnson is
implicated or
in in other inquiries should he resign
well i don't think we've quite got to
that yet i mean i think the important
point that's what i'm
suggesting we're looking ahead to if
there is no negative finding
about the prime minister should he
resign
there are a number of inquiries which
the commission and the others are going
to run
and obviously they're going to have to
look at the process of
all these well the ways of all these
things are funded
i mean if we only give somebody 30 000
pounds a year to refurbish which most of
it seems a lot of money
but if boris is prime minister for a
long time that would potentially give
him the opportunity of sending 300
000 pounds so i think you know these are
these amounts
um you know are quite important when you
consider that you're decorating a
a home that receives international
visitors and obviously there's got to be
a better way of funding it and i think
that's
one of the interesting debates we should
be having he can't be the first person
who's needed to decorate and not
necessarily
um known you know the total cost at the
outset
how many of us are suggesting that i'm
sorry i'm not clear on what you're
suggesting you're suggesting that 30
pounds
is sufficient or it actually isn't
sufficient
think it's an awful lot of money but on
the other hand
if you're going to do a renovation that
where you're hoping to be somewhere for
a long time
i suppose you've got to look back and
say well he spent this money
10 years ago it won't look so you know
it'll look a much more reasonable
amount so it could be uh yes
uh justified is what you're saying i
think anyway victoria
barwick and professor tim bale thank you
so much for speaking to us this morning
time for a look at the day's sport for
you now with alice
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025
well the best place it feels like to
start is the spurs game
and your performance and the result in
general how much did the club need that
to get their revenge from the previous
game that we had against them because we
still had the insight
everyone had the inside you know losing
like that at home
and um just for the point as well with
the result
that happened in the weekend that was
good for us
it was very important there was a really
nice moment after the game that the
cameras picked up you and ollie having a
little chat
it looked like he was complimenting you
on a part of your game what's your
relationship like with ollie at the
moment
well he wasn't complimenting me he was
he was telling me that i should have
scored
but but now obviously uh
we have a very good relation um
you understand me he put me on the pitch
he trusts me to uh to play in the middle
on the left
and that's all that's all the player
needs
there was a really interesting what we'd
call like a war of words between
oligonosula and jose mourinho
before the game and after the game and
it was amusing for us to watch what did
you guys make of it as players
i don't know what happened i'm sure
mourinho put something or said something
that will the people speak that's why it
does
and uh yeah we got the result that we
wanted
just uh ollie knows it and
we enjoy that enjoy that moment what do
you think the differences are between
jose mourinho's style of management and
olly gonna social style of management
what i have now with the with the oli
is different because he would he
wouldn't go against the players
maybe he doesn't put them uh it's not
like
you put them on the side and they don't
they don't exist anymore
and i think that's the difference
between mourinho and
oli because committed to getting 100
million people 20
more active by 2025.
[Music]
from today london city becomes the first
major airport in the world to use a
remote
digital control tower planes will be
directed by staff
70 miles away rather than controllers
overlooking the airfield
jemima walker reports
this now redundant control center was
once the eyes and the ears of the
airport
but now dusty binoculars have been
replaced with 14
cameras which feed live video 70 miles
away to hampshire
where panoramic screens can be overlaid
with extra data
what we're able to do is augment the
information that the air traffic
controllers would have had in our
traditional tower
with more information which is right in
front of them so that includes
radar data weather data cool sign of
aircraft
so it just gives them much more
information to operate more safely
the multi-million pound project aims to
make the airport
more efficient and safer you can see
that here in the old control tower
operators had a direct view onto the
runway
in the new one they rely on cameras
albeit very high tech ones
so systems must be totally fail safe
cyber security experts say a remote
tower
could open up the systems to attacks
but it's a threat that can be managed
there is definitely always a risk with
systems of this nature
for one thing increasing complexity is a
problem where we move from something
very simple that the kind of stereotype
image of somebody leaning over a window
with binoculars they're having cameras
and monitors and remote connections the
increased complexity
is a problem but it can be handled in
the way that would handle building any
kind of resilience system
the technology is being viewed as a
major development in the aviation sector
of course not many of us are getting our
passports out at the moment
but when we do it's likely we'll see an
increasingly digitized flying experience
this kind of remote technology could
become commonplace
jemima walker sky news
still to come on sky news breakfast
vaccinating the world
a new campaign aims to raise funds to
provide injections for the world's
poorest people
[Music]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm skye's chief
correspondent
[Music]
the enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked they were right
we hear shotguns being fired and also
tear gas is being
put around the information on this
could bring down the entire network not
just in iraq and syria
but across the world
[Music]
if we're drawing it's so so hot
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
after a mostly fine start this morning
most places will become cloudier this
afternoon with frequent showers
some of them will be locally heavy with
hail and thunder and perhaps wintry over
the high ground from the north of wales
northwards
it'll be a cool day everywhere too so
taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will be at a low level of 1
to 3 again
however some isolated pockets of
moderate pollution
are possible mainly in the south
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
campaigners are calling on the public to
help raise funds to pay for coronavirus
vaccines in the world's poorest
countries
they say without better vaccination
rates in other countries
britain remains at risk from new
mutations of
the virus well let's speak to a vaccine
campaigner and founder of charity give
them a shot jorik mohs who's joined me
now good morning
to you um what are the specific
problems that are being faced by
developing countries in terms of
vaccinations of terms of containing the
virus
thank you very much for having me on
dylan appreciate it i think
some of the large problems at the moment
um in our campaign where we're trying to
raise 100 000
pounds for uh unicef work covax facility
is the fact that they're having a
problem with getting supply to them
and that's because of a couple reasons
some because um countries in
the high income world are sort of over
ordering so campaign so
canada with population 37 billion has
ordered 5.4 times
what it needs at 400 million um the
syrian industry of india
has stopped exporting in march so that
kovacs won't
be able to get to its 100 million target
that i hope to by the end of may
it'll only get below that at 49 million
so it's as much a supply
issue as um us trying to do the good
work we are
and vaccinating our own populations but
there are others who really need it as
well
so tell us about the get one give two
campaign um
what what that's trying to do
essentially
thank you for asking so what we're
asking the british public to do
is when they get their first or second
dose we're asking them to get
one give to so give the equivalent of
two doses which for the astrazeneca
um vaccine would be about six pounds to
our campaign
act give them a shot dot code uk and are
you confident that people
will see the need i mean there are those
who say you know charity begins at home
we haven't vaccinated our entire
population
and that should be our first um
port of call before we start helping
others
of course we completely understand that
but we've been lucky enough to vaccinate
over 50
of our population we've got a shot at a
normal-ish 2021 you know
today we're looking at a rave in
liverpool testing that or potentially
going to places like
portugal malta in mid-may and we know
that the british public are a generous
and empathetic bunch you know where we
saw the captain's tomorrow last year
every other year we
see with um comic relief so um
six pounds hopefully it won't uh will be
a small enough amount to encourage
people to help others
and show that empathy which we know the
british public had in spades
and what impact will delayed vaccination
have on
developing countries
i think some of the big challenges are
that you know whereas we might have
you know even full vaccination but ended
this year some estimates are that
some countries won't have that level of
vaccination by the mid or even the end
of 2023 that's a 60
level of overall vaccination
and what that means is mutations might
still happen um i know
epidemiologists but that's what i've
been told and likewise
they could quite easily come here but
also schools will continue to be closed
debts will increase the rack up and then
the economic development which is
already widening gap will get even wider
as they don't get the chance to get
their people to work
to export etc or even need tourism
dollars that
will help them to develop develop their
economies and we do hear constantly
don't we that no one's
safe until we're all safe it is a global
village so it might seem
a distant problem but actually it could
affect us eventually
very much so i mean we we talk about um
the indian stray and the can strain and
other strains will happen if
many people aren't vaccinating reduce
that transmission rate and so
they're almost the best chance for us
and going on all our exotic holidays and
whether it's the 1.6 million people that
go into south africa or others
is to and vaccine the world as well as
ourselves
and i take it because of the campaign
you don't believe that uh
we're doing enough to share vaccines and
to consider other countries
through this pandemic
the uk has donated 568 million pounds to
um
to kovac which is a really good
commitment but we also know that it's
um that the overseas development has
gone down from
0.7 to 0.5 of gdp which is about 4
billion so
there's a gap which we used to give
which we could donate further and
and likewise a lot of the the pledge
money there's sort of eight over eight
billion dollars that's been pledged to
kovacs has come from
often governments and so there's a real
opportunity to tap into those
private donations that that private
generosity to to help others
how much are you hoping to raise and in
effect how many vaccines
we're hoping to raise 100 000 um pounds
for unicef
um and that will help support the work
they do with kovacs
through um vaccinating frontline
healthcare workers 20
through delivering the vaccines and i'm
hopefully purchasing as well
europe thank you so much for speaking to
us behind the campaign get one
give two good to speak to you thank you
thank you very much let's take a look at
the weather for you now with nice
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's a case of april
showers for today the last day of
april we'll be seeing some heavy showers
moving along this afternoon
very slow moving once the winds will be
light and in fact it stays
showery for the rest of this week and
for bank holiday monday
very wet and windy to begin with this
morning though not
too bad mostly dry conditions around
inland areas but coastal parts are
seeing quite a few showers particularly
heavy at the moment
around the southeast of scotland and
northeast england and then as we go into
this afternoon the cloud amounts will
increase and as that cloud bubbles up
then more frequent showers are likely
now it's going to be quite hit and miss
some
areas may not see any showers at all all
day most likely across northern ireland
and later the southeast of scotland will
be
largely dry but elsewhere i think
there's a pretty good chance of seeing a
shower or two some of them
as i said with the light winds will be
slow moving with the risk of some heavy
downpours some thundery ones and some
hail
and on top of that temperatures well
below average for the time of year